[Music]
hello everyone thank you for coming this
is the session on enterprise security
and G suite tools
I'm renown ed Kearney product manager on
the G suite team we also have with us
today
Ivonne pesos my colleague who's gonna
show us some great demos so let's start
by thinking about why this matters why
does enterprise cloud security matter
Gartner recently said that the clouds
for strategies are the foundation of
staying relevant in this fast-paced
world so as you can see cloud is a
fundamental once in a generation shift
and you as leaders of innovation cannot
afford to get left behind but we
understand that these shift to the cloud
come with some significant risks risks
to your enterprise to your data as you
move this data to the cloud also to your
end-users so you may be convinced but
not all of your end-users may be
convinced and finally a personal risk to
you this is your professional reputation
your job at stake if you make the
decision to go to the cloud and I bet
none of you wants to be on CNN for the
wrong reasons I want you to know that at
Google we take this responsibility very
seriously let's first start with our
product principles at Google we aim to
build in security at all levels you saw
in the keynote this morning right from
our custom hardware chips our data
centers a network infrastructure our
software as well as end-users and
endpoints like mobile second we aim to
make our security easy and natural to
use not just for the end-users but also
for the administrators we want the
security to
just work and not get in the way of you
doing your work and lastly we want to
aim to help our customers meet their
compliance needs in security scale
matters Google has seven properties with
over a billion users each you're
familiar with these Gmail search Play
Android YouTube and others seven
properties with over a billion users
each and with G suite the security team
that takes care of these products is now
working for you but we don't just stop
there we have groups of security
researchers and former hackers who are
continuously monitoring our system we
also proactively invite the community to
help us hack our systems we run bug
bounty programs where we have external
hackers come and try to hack our systems
but I'm sorry to say most of the time
they get this t-shirt that says I tried
to hack Google but all I got was this
lousy t-shirt here welcome to try by the
way so that is the solid foundation of
Google security that we build our
products upon on top of that we add G
suite are always listening learning and
designing to the concerns of our top
customers in my conversations with our
CIOs CIA soars IT administrators somehow
three themes seem to keep bubbling back
up and we will talk about each of them
today phishing data breaches and mobile
management obviously our customers are
very worried about these and with this
session I want to leave you with a sense
of familiarity and comfort of all the
tools that we have in each of these
areas let's talk about phishing
users still fall for a well-defined
phishing page 50% of the time
phishing is still the number one way
someone's gonna get malware into your
organization's as you know passwords can
be easily stolen and their week did you
know that two of the most commonly used
passwords last year were one two three
four five six and the word password so
clearly we have a problem here an OTP
codes can also be fished so what do we
do we recommend that you use security
keys security keys are easy they're
great they help you prevent against
phishing what we've also done is that we
have now added some admin controls to be
able to manage these security keys at
scale we now allow you to enforce the
usage of security keys in your domain we
allow you to let you use yourself enroll
these security keys if you wanted to if
a user lost their security key or it got
stolen
you can help that user recover it and
finally you can now report on the usage
of security key within your domain
I'm gonna call Yvonne on stage to show
us a demo of how this looks Yvonne can
you guys hear me yes okay so can we
switch to the computer
there you go okay so I'm gonna show you
two different views of how this works
one is the admin which is what you see
now and you will also see how a user
perceives this feature so the first
thing is to set up security keys for a
domain and you will see on the left hand
side here that I can select this / oh
you organization unit within the domain
you basically have to answer three
questions number one do you want to
enforce this immediately or in a future
date and we recommend that you do it in
a future date so that you have time to
communicate with your users and let them
know they should be receiving security
keys they need to self-enroll etcetera
etcetera
once you make that decision you also
need to choose whether you want to allow
all types of - just sexual factor
authentication which could be OTP or
security keys or just securities as
reanimation OTP is also feasible but in
some cases you may not be able to deploy
security is only to everyone but if you
select only security key you need to
make another choice which is if your
user loses or gets the security key
stolen how much time of a grace period
will you allow them to use another
method until they receive the new
security key and that's setup right here
that's it that's all you need to do just
set it up now I'm gonna switch to the
user view to show you how easy for a
user security key the use of security
key is so right now I'm logging in as a
regular user and because I set up
security key enforcement on the domain
I'm gonna be prompted so would you like
to register your security key I have my
security key here that I received from
my admin and then I can just click
register I'm gonna be verified on my
identity again have your scary key yes
next I'm gonna plug in the security key
and I would touch it and that's it
that's all I need to do once I touch the
security key I have it registered every
time I have to login again it will
request for me to touch the security key
which does it your factor authentication
and you can of course have these saved
on computers that you trust for 30 days
that's a choice the user has in addition
to that I showed you initially the
enforcement I showed you the self enroll
as the user and I'm going back to the
admin view to deal with a situation
where the user has lost the security key
so that's the recover the freedom
mentioned in this case let's say that it
alone lost his security key they called
in let the admin know the first thing
you would do is going to the user and
then go into the security key settings
and revoke the security key that
basically makes whatever was lost
completely unusable so here is for that
user the security that was just
registered here and then you can revoke
it done that's security cannot be used
anymore until it's registered somewhere
else the other step is you can
immediately provide that user with OTP
codes so that while they are without a
security key they can continue to do
their work until they receive a new one
register that again and then they are
able to use the security keys again
these keys or these codes will only work
during that grace period that you had
set up before so that's how we can
enforce its Jojo factor authentication
even in the case of losing the security
key in in addition to that that is the
reporting side so the admin console has
built-in reports that allow it to track
how many people have enrolled on
security keys which users are still
pending in that way you can plan to
extend your security key enrollment
period whether you are on track and make
decisions on how to deploy it so again
security keys are very easy for the
admin to set up very easy for the users
to actually use on a daily basis and
they do enforce a very important part
of security which is preventing fishing
and now I'm gonna call Rena back to talk
about the next step on the issues that
IP worries about thank you
Thank You Yvonne next we're gonna talk
about data breaches this is a very
important area because data breaches are
growing at an alarming rate I think
you're familiar with this but just in
the last year we've had our hackers
infiltrate some very trusted names Sony
Target Home Depot JPMorgan eBay Yahoo
and even the health insurance provider
anthem we've had over 1,000 data
breaches occur just in 2016
over 35 million critical personal
records have now been compromised
to hackers I'm happy to tell you that we
have several new features in this area
to help protect your data better as you
know over a year ago we launched Gmail
DLP what this feature allowed you to do
was to stop end users in your
organization from leaking data
accidentally or intentionally it allowed
you to either stop people from leaking
the information or be able to send it
but give them a warning that they
shouldn't be sending it and notify the
admin we're now extending that DLP
platform to drive as well we recently
announced this functionality just last
month the DLP is now available for drive
as well what we are doing in DLP for
Drive is that first of all we have many
predefined content detectors for you so
this is sensitive data formats from
across the world this includes license
numbers social security numbers and such
from the United States
you could have CPF numbers from
avance come free confidential
information is not compromised
we have pan account numbers from India
and worldwide we have over 50 predefined
content types we also have predefined
content thresholds a lot of the tools on
the market what they do is that they
provide you with so many false positives
that as an admin you kind of get tired
of getting these alerts and you may miss
something so instead what we are
allowing you to do is that you can
adjust these to your level of perceived
risk so we talked a little bit about the
content detectors as well as the
thresholds but what's important here is
that we also provide flexibility as part
of the system so you can only you can
not only have these predefined content
detectors but let's say your healthcare
company where you're doing research and
the keywords that you want to protect
haven't been invented yet
so we allow you to be able to upload a
set of keywords that are relevant to
your business and your data we also
allow you to duke optical character
recognition on these attachments that
are going out so just to be very clear
on what's happening here and the power
of our platform not only are we scanning
the emails to protect your data we're
scanning the attachments that are going
out with these emails we can even scan
not only these emails and attachments
but zipped attachments and on these
zipped attachments if there are images
we can do pattern matching and do
optical character recognition for each
of these content types like credit card
numbers and social security numbers so
it's a really powerful way to stop data
from leaking outside your organization
so with that I'm gonna call Yvonne to do
a demo and show you how this actually
works
Yvonne thanks Rina okay so I'm gonna
again play two roles admin and user in
each case the user is Rena who is
working on a project
- basically review all the credit card
expenses in the company so this document
was created here to start that project
and the collection and it has a lot of
credit card numbers those numbers of
course are sensitive information that is
also information about employees here
and you will notice that the first thing
that's visible here on the share button
there is a shield that's already drive
the OPC if you're gonna share this
information be careful and it even says
this has credit card number information
so be careful when you share this with
anyone
and of course Rena needs to share this
with the rest of the team so she's gonna
go here and try to share this with her
colleague Freddie Mac notice what
happens here Rena probably has
communicated with Freddie on both
personal and company email and both of
them showed up Rinas in a hurry so she
clicks on the gmail address
it just shows Freddie Mac now so she
went to try to send this and what
happens is dop detects that that is
going outside of the domain tells Reena
that this cannot go outside of the
domain so I'm blocking this and once you
click OK it actually allows you to go
back to the same screen and make the
changes that you would need so how does
this magic work as you can see for
reena's flow this hasn't impacted in any
way the way she would need work she can
still reach out to her colleagues get
work done but on the admin side this is
done very simply by setting up rules so
these are the rules that are currently
in the system so I'm now in the admins
view and the rules that are currently in
the system cover different types of data
including the credit card numbers data
which is the rule that actually caught
that specific file I'm gonna go through
the process of setting up a role just
for you to see how that would work so
let's say you need to set up a new rule
there are multiple templates here that
you can use to start I'm going to start
from a blank template but you don't need
you if you know already what you're
looking for in these fits one of the
pre-existing templates
to create a really basically to look at
three things number one what type of
data should trigger this is a specific
rule in this case is Google Drive you
would look at conditions and Reena
mentions some of this before users will
define the scope of those conditions or
of the rule whether it's the entire
company whether it's specific or use or
even specific groups once you set that
up you can define the content in in the
content you may select predefined
templates those are the templates that
Reena was talking about even my home
country Brazil is covered here I'm gonna
select social security just for for the
demo you can also select custom word
lists that you can build yourself or
regular expressions and based on that
selection you can also select ESRI
dimension confidence level so you don't
get more false positives than you were
willing to deal with once you've done
that the next step is defining the
actions so once the trigger happens what
actions do I want to be taken you can do
one or both of these options one is
notify these super admins that this
trigger happened and or either block
external access or simply warn external
access or external sharing in this case
you may have cases where you say be
careful when you are sharing financial
statements because they may not be
public yet but do not share any social
security numbers or credit cards for
instance and that's it it's that simple
so in urges that you implement the ope
in your domain you would basically need
to set up these rules and your users
will have no disruption in their regular
flow and still be able to be protected
to have that they are protected by the
Fe that's it
bacteria next we continue our journey to
put you in better control of your
information the Gmail logs in bigquery
what we're doing here is allowing you to
export all of your Gmail logs into
bigquery as good as we have our
reporting we have customers telling us
hey can I do my own custom queries so
this will allow you to do that
this allows you to retain your data for
longer periods of time as well as you
can use a data visualization tool like
data studio from Google or you could use
third-party tools like tableau or Splunk
that you're already using within your
environment staying with Gmail s/mime
encryption for Gmail as you know as mime
is an industry standard way of
encrypting email what's special here is
that we are allowing our customers to
bring their own certificates to be able
to do encryption using their own
certificates we're also providing an
admin API to be able to do this at scale
for large companies we've talked a lot
about the new features that are coming
up with Gmail however I want to point
out that there have been many features
of Gmail security that have been
existing in place for a long time that
people don't realize we already have one
example that is not listed here but the
TLS warning that we read that recently
added the transport layer security
warning that just gave an indication if
a domain did not encrypt their email and
that fundamentally changed how many
domains out there were doing TLS the
next one here is to prevent outgoing
spam with Demark this allowed people to
control someone else from going out
there and sending unauthenticated emails
on your behalf and then finally we also
have really solid spam and abuse
policies in place where gmail is doing
the work for you along with all of these
features we also have security workshops
that we run for our customers so about
three months after the product G suite
gets deployed in your environment either
someone from Google or someone from a
partner can come and run a security
workshop for you and they can come and
verify all of your security settings to
make sure that you're appropriately
protected deep scanning of Gmail
attachments this is one of my favorite
upcoming features it's
already available in trusted tester for
our customers the time between a first
malicious email entering into your
organization to the first user opening
this attachment and then spreading
malware into your entire organization is
very little so what you want to do as an
IT administrator is ideally get ahead of
that process so with the pre-delivery
scanning of email attachments what we
are able to do is we are able to open
these attachments in an secure sandbox
environment run them to make sure that
there are no malicious scripts or bad
acting going on in each of these
attachments so this is something to
watch out for and it's already available
in trusted tester switching gears a
little bit to a different product in our
portfolio is Google Plus as you know
Google Plus is a relatively new addition
I think in q3 of last year we added
Google Plus to our commercial suite a
lot of large customers are using this
product to make cultural change happen
within their organization I'll give you
some examples rolling out large
initiatives from their executives for
some reason there are always those
three-pronged initiatives right so to be
able to roll out these initiatives in
your organization across multiple Geo's
our customers are using Google Plus
they're also using Google Plus to do
Bottoms Up ideation we have a large
retail customer where they have store
employees who have really good ideas to
be able to improve the overall company
and until now they were just not able to
get that voice heard so they are using
these dynamic communities across the
company to bring out these ideas so I'm
happy to share that we have several new
admin features that are now coming up
for this product I'll give you some
examples the first one is the domain
level adoption engagement metrics what
we often hear from admins is that hey
this product is great it's being used
quite a bit in our company but I have no
way to show the impact so now we can
show them how many people engaged with
certain posts hoop last one certain
posts and such second we have the audit
log API what this does we have one
customer I'll give you an example we
have one customer which is a large bank
and they have a small group of users
their brokers these brokers are required
to be highly monitored and so what
they're doing here is that they have
brought in a partner that partner is
building a compliance solution on top of
our audit log api's finally the number
one requested feature in this product is
the walled garden feature this allows
the admin to stop people from externally
sharing content within their domain from
outside their domain and stopping IP
leakage so that full domain sharing and
such restrictions is what we internally
called as walled garden and that's
coming soon as well so we talked a lot
about the solid protections that we're
putting in place for our first party
products like email for drive and others
but what about third-party applications
we have a new feature in place
third-party apps whitelisting and this
is also already available in trusted
tester what this does is that it allows
you to figure out which applications are
getting access to which or what scopes
and then the admin can only offer a set
of trusted applications the ability to
get to company data a good example of
this would be the concur travel app you
trust it it can have access to all of
your drive data for example but there
are many apps there are bad actors and
they overreach in terms of the odd
Scopes that they ask for recently there
was a customer where there was a very
innocent innocuous looking clock
application and many of their users
installed this clock application and it
got access to a lot of the company data
if someone some app like this a
malicious app got access to all of your
users files just imagine the
of damage it could do so I'm gonna call
Yvonne on stage to show us a demo of
third-party apps whitelisting Thank You
Reena all right so here we see again
Reena who is trying to be all she can be
looking for apps to increase their
productivity and there are two specific
apps that you found one is dock hub
which allows you to edit sign PDFs
online integrated with this suite
the other one is much sheet which allows
you to turn your sheets in your system
into a project management environment
Sarina said okay great I'm gonna try to
use these these tools and as she tried
to log in smartsheet worked and I should
try to log into a doc hub she got this
message policy enforced and she has no
idea what that is so she gets in touch
with the admin and the admin actually
knows what's going on right what the
admin did first is because of those
threats that Reena mentioned in the
presenter not the employee they had
blocked any access from any third-party
app to the G suite API and basically
what we are looking at here is you have
granular controls where you can say for
these specific apps I want to block
everyone for these other ones I want to
leave it open
in this case we had blocked driving
contacts left Gmail and calendar open
and that basically says that any
third-party app would try to access the
this with API will fail you can also
allow your own domain apps to be
automatically trusted however you notice
that one app work the other one didn't
why as Reena mention with the third
party app whitelisting you are actually
able to individually list the apps that
you trust in this case smartsheet is
listed and everybody else gets blocked
in this case that's why doc hub was
now dock hub is actually a G Street
marketplace app so as an admin I can
make the decision to say well I know we
can trust this app this is not an app
coming from nowhere it's been certified
by Google I can just go here doc hub is
right there I can add it to the
whitelist and it's very easy for you to
increase the number of apps that are
supported that you trust so that you
reach a balance between protecting your
domain in your data and enabling your
employees productivity so that's
basically it that's simple
thanks Reena right so next we're gonna
talk about vault vault is our a
discovery product that comes as part of
wait a minute Yvonne is the actual
product manager for vault
if only want to come up here and tell us
about your product he's been using me as
a bad actor in all of his demos so I'm
gonna put him on the spot come on up
here Yvonne and talk about your product
thank you very much I'll see what I can
do all right
and by the way Rina is my manager so I
better do a good job here so Google
vault is the discovery and compliance
solution for this suite how does what do
that so what basically provides you two
specific areas of functionality to allow
you to have legal compliance and prevent
data loss number one through its
retention policies what allows you to
control the specific data that you
should keep in your environment in the
data that you don't want to keep and
that allows you to be compliant with
your requirements as well as minimize
your data liability risk if you leave
data that's showed when you get to the
time where you need to produce data that
data may not be required to be there but
it may actually create trouble for you
and yes too much date in some cases is a
problem once you've done that in your
environment and you've set those
automatic policies to keep your
environment always compliant vote also
provides you with
discovery tools that allow you to
support both legal and compliance
requirements whether they are internal
investigations or specific legal cases
in lawsuits you can search and produce
data and get that data in a format that
can be used for sharing with an external
counsel or with your internal teams as
well as moving that into I specific a
discovery tool that follows up with the
process so here are some details on how
this works with retention policies you
basically can define answer a few
questions first question is what app do
you want to cover and one thing that I
would like to mention which was
announced this morning is that now we
support we have full support for Gmail
which we had and they we've added new
full support for drive including SIM
drives as well as Google Groups so
basically we can make a selection of the
app you'll need to cover the next step
is to define the scope notice there is a
similarity with other things we do like
the lp where you go with specific
criteria that you're going to use so
here you can do organizational unit
entire domain you can also do specific
entities like sim drives the next step
is duration do I want this policy to be
applicable indefinitely just keep all
the data or set it to a specific number
of days unless but not least what should
I do
once that policy expire should I get rid
of any data that matches it regardless
of whether the user has deleted it or
not that's a very aggressive policy or
should I only get rid of data that the
user has already deleted again a lot of
flexibility whilst even a simple UI and
you can have multiple policies that
match together will match your
compliance needs for your company once
that's set it would get Google part
search should get the data that you need
for a specific specific project and once
you get to the level of data that you
want you've called the data and narrow
it down to your search requirements you
can export that easily so that you can
share that with whoever needs it
that's it this is a Google vault we can
easily go discovering complaints how did
they do what do you guys think
thank you no that was great Yvonne but
to me it seems like he's been practicing
in his sleeve Thank You Yvonne he's the
actual product manager responsible for
the announcements that prabhakar made
this morning on vault let's talk about
mobile management mobile management why
is this important there's two
fundamental things are going on in
mobile management we have employees who
expect to be productive on the go
wherever they are and they don't want
security to get in the way and then you
have the admins whose goal is to keep
the company's data secure and they
really the whole exposure to risk went
up multiple times because each employee
now has multiple devices the other
problem we have is that these admins are
now managing a fundamentally different
workforce people don't stay in the same
job for 20 years we have Millennials
moving jobs every few years and then
when they do that you gotta revoke the
access they have on their devices or
take that company own device and
redeploy it to somebody else we have
people trying to jailbreak their iPhones
we have people trying to sideload
applications that they are not
authorized to on their company devices
we need to be able to give admins the
tools to be able to control this if they
need to what many customers don't
realize is that as part of the G suite
we have a comprehensive mobile device
management solution I'm going to walk
you through a quick set of features that
come with this solution so first right
from our mobile one console you're able
to manage both the company owned as well
as bring your own devices you're able to
curate and deploy third-party
applications you can look at some
reporting that I'm gonna show you here
pretty quickly as well as
take some actions using our mobile
device management solution so here is an
example of a very simple one-click setup
you click on manage now and it tells you
it's gonna allow you to do screen lock
account wipe as well as inventory
management you click on manage now and
there now mobile device management is
setup is complete and you're able to set
this up for your entire mobile fleet
next bulk enrolment of company devices
here's what happens let's say you're an
IT admin managing a fleet of about
20,000 employees and now you're CEO just
complicated your life by acquiring
another company with 3,000 new users now
you bought these new devices to be able
to get these you know users to be
productive what do you do we provide a
way for you to just take all of these
device IDs put them in a CSV file and
upload them and our system can ingest
them and with that simple thing you can
get all of these devices managed pretty
quickly
that's MDM at scale you also may have
some homegrown custom applications or
you may want to deploy some pre-approved
third-party applications we allow you to
do that using our work store you're also
able to monitor and audit these devices
you can report on the type of users the
type of devices iOS and Android versions
and such what we've also found is that
in many large customers there's not just
one admin there's teams of admins some
of these admins have delegated admin
authority managing just Gmail are just
mobile so we want to be able to enable
that scenario and you can have a
comprehensive audit log of what admin
actions were taken by each of these
admins
next we also have a risk when there is
inactive devices with the credentials of
your company's data sitting on these
inactive devices
so what we're enabling you to do is to
be able to track these inactive devices
and you can revoke credentials if you
don't want them to be there so once
you've done this monitoring and auditing
you can also take some very quick
actions you can for example revoke the
Google OAuth token or you could also
remove the Google account altogether at
Google especially in our team because we
have focused on large customers and
admins we like to remind people that
admins are people too so as an admin you
may possibly be somewhere like at your
child's birthday party and you get an
alert so we enable you to take these
actions even on the goal using our
Google mobile admin application we also
allow you to create custom workflows for
these devices using our admin api's so
for example we have our mobile crud
api's we have mobile audit api's that
you can use and it's also a way for our
partners to build and extend our
platforms using these mobile api's as
customers are discovering these features
and capabilities of the Google mobile
device management what they're realizing
is that they are paying extra for a
niche product that they don't need to
because all they were using is those 37
ActiveSync policies anyway so we've seen
a very large uptick in the adoption of
our mobile device management solution
over the last few quarters so ultimately
in the cloud security is about trust
and as you saw this morning in the
keynote you had phil garland from the PD
from PwC come and talk to you about how
they use G suite at scale these trust
security and compliance features have
had many large customers experience the
power of Google innovation and machine
learning by going Google here's a quote
from Mike who is the CIO of Whirlpool
Corporation so let's think about this we
encrypt your data at rest we encrypt
your data in transit you can use
security keys to secure your accounts in
addition to that our data centers our
applications and our processes are
audited and independently verified by
third parties and so we have these
certifications like thread ramp ISO
27001 and others one question that I
keep getting and I almost want to make a
sign that says I can't believe I have to
still keep saying this so I'm gonna say
it but what about ads people ask me
Google is an advertising company you
know are you gonna show me ads so let's
be clear in our consumer products we
have ads and that enables us to offer
these products to our consumers for free
the enterprise business the ads and our
enterprise systems they don't touch each
other we commit to no ads using our
contractual DPA the data protection
addendum so let's recap we went through
a lot of things today so let's recap
about what the things we talked about
phishing we showed you security keys and
by the way we are going to give away
security keys to each of you at the end
of this session so please as you're
exiting I see some cheers awesome as
you're exiting please make sure that you
pick one up and then second we talked
about mobile management our easy set up
being able to do bulk enrollment as well
as password lock remote wipe monitoring
and auditing and quickly taking some
actions
and we also talked quite a bit about
what we are doing to protect you against
data breaches this included data loss
prevention for Gmail and drive we talked
about how you can do advanced logs
analysis in Gmail
we also talked about s/mime encryption
walled garden and other audit API is for
Google+ we are protecting you from third
party apps data breaches with a third
party apps white listing feature and
giving you control back as an admin we
have vault for driving groups and
finally we talked about all of our
certifications I hope that gives you a
sense of comfort and a comprehensive
picture of all the solid protections
that G suite brings to you to secure
your enterprise data in the cloud with
that I'd like to end with a note of
gratitude if you are our customer thank
you for being here and thank you for
being with us if you're a prospect or a
partner we look forward to working with
you more in the future
thanks a lot
and that is our disclaimer that my legal
team made me put so in case you're going
to pick up a security key please make
sure that you read this it talks about
if you're traveling out of the country
they may you know ask you to pay a tax
it's this small so we'll see
[Music]
you